Hello friends and fans of Indiana Jones
welcome to Rotten Tomatoes countdown
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
has finally arrived and with it comes
the end of an iconic film franchise that
has spanned five decades and five films
so I guess that makes it officially a
five ology or maybe like a five some
actually that sounds like a different
kind of movie either way we are here to
count down all five Indiana Jones movies
ranked by Tomato Meter of course here on
Rotten Tomatoes countdown so get your
outfit ready and with a tip of our
fedora hat we shall begin
[Music]
thank you
starting with number five Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny
this Fifth and final installment in the
film franchise takes place in 1969 where
Indy once again played by the Harrison
Ford and can I just say this man is
studly anyway he is in a Race Against
Time to recover a legendary dial that
can change the course of history which
sounds pretty serious now this time
around he's joined by his goddaughter
played by none other than Phoebe Waller
Bridge who seems to be the perfect
companion for bouncing off ornery
one-liners and going on death defying
chases through small villages
you end up like this
very beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
hold on
seriously nobody can deliver a one-liner
like Phoebe Waller bridge now joining
forward is John Reese Davis and Karen
Allen repricing their roles as Salah and
Marion Ravenwood from earlier films
along with additional newcomers played
by Antonio Banderas and mads Mickelson
the latter which plays a former Nazi who
works for NASA aka the bad guy I gotta
say mads he got a record for being good
bad guys now this is actually the lowest
rated film in the series of course the
easy explanation would be that this is
the first and only one not directed by
Steven Spielberg and without a story by
George Lucas they are both credited as
executive producers instead but that
would be writing off director and
co-writer James Mangold whose resume
made him very qualified for the job
ultimately while the Nostalgia of seeing
Ford back in Indie action one more time
is great critics are of the consensus
that the adventures just aren't as
thrilling anymore sad face emoji
number four Indiana Jones and the
kingdom of the Crystal Skull ah yes
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull the one
with the aliens and Shia LaBeouf and the
one critics seem to like but fans not so
much now this one takes place 19 years
after the Last Crusade and it's actually
set in 1957 where Indy searches for a
telepathic crystal skull while going up
against Soviet KGB agents led by Kate
Blanchett now Karen Allen reprized her
role as the love interest Marion
Ravenwood from Raiders of the Lost Ark
who now shares a sign with Indiana named
Mott played by Shaya and while there are
plenty of similarities revealed between
Father and Son a fear of snakes is not
one of them
[Music]
go get something else like what
look like a rope or something there's no
Sears in Roblox you grab the snake
maybe I can touch the ball there is no
bottom I think I can feel it with my
feet grab the snake I'm calling it that
it's a snake what do you want me to call
it hey bro what hey grab the Rope
grab the Rope now the idea of a sun came
about after old Indy was revealed to
have a daughter in the young Indiana
Jones Chronicles which was a TV show
from the 90s by the time this movie
happens Spielberg thought that the
daughter idea was too similar to a
storyline in the Lost World Jurassic
Park so instead he made it a sun or
shall we say a mutt thanks for that
Steve now Ford was 64 at the time and
still put in a few hours a day at the
gym to prepare to go along with his
bullwhip training obvi and thanks to
stunt technology coming a long way since
the 80s he actually performed a few of
his own to help improve his performance
and we would expect nothing less from
the studly Harrison Ford now of course
Ford was praised by critics in his
certified fresh offering while things
like the dialogue storyline and CGI
Overkill were kind of criticized number
three Indiana Jones and the Temple of
Doom so this marks the second film in
the franchise but it's considered a
prequel to avoid having Nazis as the
villain again and is set a year or so
before the events of Raiders of the Lost
Ark which came out a few years prior
stick with me here now for this
adventure Dr Jones teams out with a
nightclub singer played by Kate cupshop
who would go on to marry the film's
director Steven Spielberg ah I love a
Hollywood romance now also along for the
ride to recover a precious gem and
several kidnapped boys with 12 year old
Short Round with a memorable performance
by kiwi Kwan who was selected for nearly
6 000 actors now also making an
appearance in this film was Harrison
Ford's buff arms like in this famous
scene on the bridge okay I'll stop now
oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
[Music]
he's crazy
George Lucas who's credited with temple
of Doom's story teamed up with writers
Willard Hoyt and Gloria Katz from
American Graffiti rather than his
Raiders collaborator Lawrence kazdan now
the result was more harsh reviews from
critics at least initially who thought
it was too dark and violent but the
critical opinion has improved over the
years citing its imagination and
intensity I mean people's opinions are
allowed to change and evolve over time
no way
number two Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade so this 1989 film set the tone
for a strong third installment with an
opening prologue that features One River
Phoenix as young Indy and gives a short
origin story for the character now from
there present-day Indy embarks on a
search for a holy grail and in the
process stumbles upon another
archaeologist who had disappeared trying
the same thing his own father played by
Sean Connery and together they partake
in the age-old father-son tradition of
evading Nazis
sharing my hair back
[Music]
no ticket
now director Steven Spielberg who called
this his favorite in the franchise was
looking to recapture the tone of Raiders
of the Lost Ark so he brought back
Indy's friends John Reese Davies as
Salah and denholm Elliott as Marcus
Brody now what Spielberg got was a
certified fresh hit the highest grossing
movie of 1989 and an Oscar for best
sound effects editing and with that
critics sung-high praise for last
Crusades pacing suspense strong themes
and the aforementioned Connery AKA
another big star for Harrison Ford to
shine with it also just kind of feels
like their father and son in real life
maybe that's just me
number one Raiders of the Lost Ark what
was once called The Adventures of
Indiana Smith was first dreamed up by
George Lucas in the mid 70s he would go
on and team up with director Steven
Spielberg along with a few other
Hollywood Earth movers at the time and
in 1981 we got Raiders of the Lost Ark
now after beating out names like Bill
Murray Nick Nolte Jeff Bridges and Tom
Selleck this actually marked Harrison
Ford's first run as renowned
archaeologist Dr Jones he's hired by the
U.S government to find the Ark of the
Covenant which is also being sought
after by Hitler and from there with
thanks to a whip and a leather Fedora a
major action franchise and hero was born
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
now along with introducing a few
characters that we would meet again like
Marion and Salah this was also the first
ever feature film for Alfred Molina who
played a guide and his first day of
filming involved him being covered with
tarantulas welcome to show business I
could never now Raiders of the Lost Ark
has the highest Tomato Meter and
audience scores in the franchise and
it's the only one to receive an Oscar
nomination for best picture it also went
on to become the highest grossing film
of 1981 beating Superman 2 and well I
just gotta say that is stupendous
all right my friends that is all five
Indiana Jones flakes ranked by Tomato
Meter we'll see you in another 15 years
when Harrison Ford does one more I'm
kidding but maybe not now for more on
this long-standing franchise and it's
very fresh installment head on over to
rottentomatoes.com thank you so much for
checking out today's list I love when
you guys listen to these until next time
I'm your host Naz Perez and we'll see
you back here for more Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
foreign
[Music]